[Musique]
bonsoir est heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau 7,8 les invités voici
les titres
nous ferons un point sur la plateforme
en temps réel de recrutement lourd père
lui dit jobs lancé vendredi dernier le
nouveau site lancé par une société de
maurepas permet d'interagir en vidéo
lors de votre recherche d'emploi
nous en discuterons avec l'un des
fondateurs christophe marre j'ai dit non
débute ce 7,8 les invités avec le civic
dating cette initiative qui se déroulera
le 8 mars prochain au pôle jeunesse à
montigny a pour but de mettre en
relation les jeunes et les associations
dans le cadre du service civique pour en
parler laurence cousin la directrice
yvelines information jeunesse
bonsoir bonsoir alors ceci vite dating
qu'est ce qui se passe le lui mars
alors ce civil dating est organisé par
la ville de montigny le bretonneux donc
le service jeunesse et vie des quartiers
au pôle jeunesse ou nous mêmes nous
sommes installés depuis plus d'un an
maintenant et donc ils nous ont délégué
l'organisation de cet événement alors le
civic dating c'est quoi c'est en fait
c'est en fait la mise en relation comme
vous l'avez dit oui exactement mais pour
des missions de volontaires donc ce sont
des missions de volontariat pour des
jeunes qui sont âgés entre 16 et 25 ans
public élargi jusqu'à 30 ans pour les
donc les personnes en situation de
handicap et qui souhaitent s'engager sur
une mission d'intérêt général les
peuples de conditions c'est il ya pas de
condition de diplôme en tout cas dans la
première chose c'est la motivation le
premier critère en fait pour pour
s'engager
c'est pas un emploi donc ils sont
indemnisés mais dont il ya pas de
rémunération c'est vraiment du
volontariat et c'est sur différentes
missions d'intérêt général qui peuvent
aussi bien concerner l'environnement la
culture alors pas que associatif c'est
vrai qu'on a dit association qu'elle va
recevoir principalement des associations
ça peut également être des services de
l'état des collectivités des fondations
donc c'est ouvert au cou l'année
dernière il ya eu plus de 900 service
civique ont été faits c'était quoi le
sur le département la sonnerie c'était
quoi le style de d'emploi qui pouvait
avoir
alors c'est pas de l'emploi mais
l'émission en fait heures sur l'année
dernière effectivement c'est la
solidarité qui a été qui a été la
mission lalalala plus la plus sollicitée
le sport également et l'éducation c'est
les trois thèmes qui sont ressortis
aujourd'hui cette année on a déjà 300
volontaires engagés et l'objectif est de
d'avoir entre 600 et 700 jeunes en
volontariat sur le sur le département
des yvelines sur désagréments
départementaux en fait c'est la
direction départementale de la cohésion
sociale des yvelines qui propose les
agréments structures qui souhaitent
intégrer des volontaires sur le
département via trois thèmes solidarité
éducation et sport c'est bien ça c'est
les troisièmes les plus sollicités mais
vous avez également alors je vais
regarder non je vous ai parlé de
l'environnement interventions d'urgence
en cas de crise tout ce qui concerne la
mémoire et la citoyenneté la santé
développement international et action
humanitaire
donc il ya de nombreuses missions
intéressantes notamment sur le
département mais au niveau national et
ça peut être en france mais également à
l'étranger
vous avez beaucoup de demandes de la
part des jeunes ils viennent ils sont en
demande de ce service civil alors ça
peut être un tremplin ça dépend en fait
dans quelle situation et le jeune
effectivement c'est vrai que quelquefois
ils peuvent être en rupture scolaire il
peut être à la recherche d'un emploi et
ces démissions je voulais pas dit mme
effectivement qui peuvent durer entre
six mois et un an
et c'est vrai que ça peut être un
formidable tremplin pour quelqu'un qui
n'est pas inquiet par exemple à la
recherche d'un an
ou tout simplement aussi quand on a le
temps de s'engager quelquefois on a
envie de s'engager mon appel tant il se
trouve que dans son parcours un jeune
peut avoir le temps et là c'est vraiment
le dispositif idéal pour s'engager et
vous avez des exemples de personnes qui
continuent derrière avec ces
associations par exemple nous mêmes on a
à deux reprises donc intégrer des
volontaires dans notre structure et il
ya un accompagnement c'est à dire que le
jeune va pas le prendre comme volontaire
6 mois 1 an qui après lui dire au revoir
l'idée c'est un tutorat ils sont
accompagnés tout au long de leur mission
et l'idée c'est aussi de devoir après ce
qui va ce qui va se passer pour eux et
nous les deux jeunes qu'on a recruté en
service civique sont repartis avec un
cdi parce qu'on a un réseau parce qu'on
a des contacts et qu'on les accompagne
aussi pour la presse alors là des
associations viennent recruter on peut
dire ce mot la peau tout à fait alors
comment il faut se présenter ce jour la
motivation et puis voilà la motivation
nous au niveau du réseau information
jeunesse déjà on peut les accompagner et
vérifier que leur projet et ça peu après
le site du service civique est très très
bien fait ils peuvent se créer un espace
voir l'émission au préalable c'est
toujours mieux de réfléchir à sa
motivation et sur le type de structure
dans lequel on a envie de travailler
plutôt que d'arriver comme ça sans avoir
plus d'informations ça peut être aussi
le cas
l'idée c'est de savoir se présenter et
puis d'être en capacité de voilà de
d'exprimer ses motivations d'être
curieux aussi sur la structure qui va
nous éventuellement nous accueillir
poser des questions et curieux et et
voir si c'est l'équation en fait faut
que ça marche tu vois en fait c'est ça
et donc c'est l'idée du dating
finalement c'est vraiment de les mettre
en relation les uns les autres pour
qu'ils aient des voilà donc ça ça puisse
se faire par la suite et qui peuvent
trouver la structure d'accueil et les
associations font vraiment en demande a
complètement bien sûr vous lui tout à
fait là donc
mercredi nous allons avoir entre neuf et
dix structures qui seront présentes et
qui recherchent à deux volontaires il ya
potentiellement la direction et les
finances qui recherche qui sera
peut-être présente on aura une réponse
définitive demain et qui la recherche
dit mission parce qu'ils ont eu neuf
sites sur tout le département et donc
ils sont recherche
deux volontaires et bien merci madame
cousin vous restez avec nous sur le
plateau on va continuer à parler de
recrutement
mais cette fois ci d'une du recrutement
sur internet et plus précisément de
d'ingénieurs c'est plutôt ça bonsoir
alors en soit on va oui pas forcément
d'un ingénieur mais des gens on va dire
en fait les différents clients avec qui
nous travaillons sur la plateforme
alors je te présente quand même vous
êtes vous faites partie vous êtes co
fondateur de ftc digital item cabinet de
recrutement et qui a lancé la semaine
dernière une nouvelle plate forme
innovante inédite de mise en relation en
temps réel examen sera bien présenté
alors je tiens à souligner par contre je
suis désolé j'ai un peu fatigué parce
que c'était compliqué la mise en oeuvre
l'on a maintenant ça roule
donc oui je suis fondateur et avec mon
associé michel grade belle personne avec
qui on a travaillé sur cette plateforme
mais en fait en relation des candidats
et des recruteurs
les recruteurs viennent déposer leurs
annonces les candidats se connecte sur
l'or leur espace viennent échanger on en
voile nous de notre côté le cv aux
recruteurs en temps réel et si le
recruteur souhaite avoir un entretien
avec le candidat
on les met tous les deux en relation sur
notre plateforme
ils peuvent échanger en vidéo en tchat
et comme ça le recrutement se passe plus
rapidement il n'y a pas de perte de
temps
c'était une demande des entreprises ce
côté vidéo c'est quand même innovantes
alors c'était une demande s'était aussi
à une attente alors l'attend parce que
aujourd'hui le recrutement
on est passé de l'âge de pierre parlant
pour le terme je ne voudrais pas démonté
des autres entreprises
mais c'est à dire qu'on est passé à l'
recrutement 4.0 on était au 2.0 ne
sommes pas si aucun 2.0 qui dit
qu'aujourd'hui on veut à un recrutement
plus rapide la sttr que aujourd'hui vous
prenez n'importe quelle personne qui
recherche un poste
la déprime
va de soi elle vous dit j'ai envoyé mon
cv sur une offre d'emploi que j'ai pu
voir à tel endroit
je n'ai pas de retour alors que là il ya
un retour automatique on s'est
directement son esprit ou pas voilà
exactement c'est à dire que la personne
le candidat qui vient s'inscrire sur le
site internet va pouvoir aller consulter
des offres d'emplois selon son critère
serre selon ses envies de travailler on
va embaucher bien pardon je m'exprime
mal si par exemple le recruteur dépose
une annonce où il souhaite recruter en
cdi un développeur et que la personne le
candidat s'est inscrit en tant que
développeur il va pouvoir répondre
l'instant t au recruteur choses
différentes aussi par rapport aux
entreprises qui déposent leurs offres
d'emploi
nous on fait de l'offre d'emploi en
temps réel alors j'entends temps réel
c'est à dire que ce sont des offres
d'emploi avec des dates de démarrage
d'accord bouclier une date de démarrage
date de fin et vous vous sélectionnez en
fait les personnes qui viennent sur
votre site ou tout on peut participer
alors tout alors tout le monde peut
venir sur le site mais tout le monde ne
peut pas répondre à toutes les offres
proposées c'est à dire qu'en fait nous
notre équipe fait une sélection faite de
cv correspondant aux besoins du
recruteur ou pennant voix voilà c'est ça
on envoie aux recruteurs le cvs
correspondants
et si le recruteur nous dit je souhaite
rencontrer cette personne nous les
mettons en relation sur la plateforme
ensemble ils peuvent échanger nous avons
notre propre modérateur qui écoute les
conversations et à partir de là voilà le
processus suit son chemin et
le cdi ou la mission peut être engagée
suite à ça et donc le recruteur
j'imagine que vous en avez rencontré pas
mal avant de lancer ce site là s'il
voulait ce côté vidéo c'est échanges
plus rapide avec on va dire les
potentiels collaborateurs
alors je vais me prendre un exemple la
dernière entreprise avec qui nous avons
rencontré nous avons placé les candidats
sans sens en visu serre que nous avons
notre notre client nous a dit voilà j'ai
besoin de d'admin systèmes et réseaux
est-ce que vous avez ça me proposer ce
que vous avez des candidats proposés
nous avons proposé les candidats et nous
l'avons proposé à eux en fait notre
entreprise avec qui nous travaillons
d'être le bêta testeurs de de cette
vidéo
ils ont été ok et aujourd'hui nous ont
ils ont embauché six personnes grâce à
l'intermédiaire de la vidéo
ils étaient des demandeurs de ceux de ce
format en fête sacrée en fait une
proximité c'est ça c'est une proximité
c'est un échange qui est on va dire plus
rapide
un échange qui est il n'y a pas de perte
de temps aussi bien côté
candidats et recruteurs et il ya pas de
faux espoirs des deux côtés pas de faux
espoirs s'est on est là ok ça match tant
mieux ça ne marche pas je peux voir une
autre offre
donc en gros on doit être toujours bien
apprêtée préparer à un entretien devant
son ordinateur
s'il vous prend mère exactement on peut
être en pyjama en dessous il tonné en
roannais en cravate et chemise au dessus
ou en dessous si vous êtes en caleçon
sépia pas de voie là et aussi bien des
filles que des garçons c'est qu'on a eu
aussi sur un recrutement là on a on l'a
recruté j'ai un client qui a recruté
quatre filles quatre demoiselles dans le
domaine de l'informatique et s'est très
bien passé donc très bien et bien je
vous remercie merci d'être venu sur le
plateau de 7,8 les invités c'est la fin
de cette émission merci de nous avoir
suivis et surtout bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]